ever since i can remember i had the
dream to start my own
organic soap company that was the reason
why i took this job in the first place
but there i was working in the marketing
department of a big brand as a junior
administrator
and instead of being excited to work for
this famous company
i was frustrated about how things were
handled i felt completely
lonely with my ideas to make a positive
impact
i spent the entire next weekend studying
different pitch formats
i figured that it would be best to
follow the requirements of one of the
big startup accelerators
if i could pitch to one of them i could
certainly pitch to the marketing
director
i opted for a pitch deck which is based
on the following six elements
the problem my solution the business
model
the market the competition our team
[Music]
okay so the problem well most body
soap brands not only lack a truly
refreshing smell
but more importantly they also sell in
cheap throwaway plastic containers
which often last not more than a month
new modern consumers however
see body soap as a lifestyle choice and
they want to have a solution that not
only works but also smells
incredibly refreshing and is
environmentally friendly
my solution i call elements it's an
organic soap which comes in four
fantastic flavors water sky earth
and fire in the first order customers
get all four flavors and a beautiful
glass jar
and with a click of a button they get
refill packs sent to their home in
sustainable carton packages
the business model is the result of our
understanding of the lifetime value of a
customer
my customers will be very loyal as they
made a clear lifestyle choice to buy it
the first purchase someone makes is
therefore just seen as an
investment we make into a long lasting
relationship
it will cost customers 25 us dollars and
they get a beautiful glass jar and the
trial set of all four flavors
the money we make later from selling the
refill packs in sustainable paper bags
for 15 us dollars
similar to the famous razor and blades
business model
the market is enormous in the beginning
we will target urban women aged 20 to 30
years
living in the united states they are
well educated they care about the
environment
and are interested to express themselves
through lifestyle choices
based on my research they spend on
average around 50 to 100
on body soap each year as there are
around 15 million women in the us who
are in their 20s
living in urban areas the total market
opportunity is at least
750 million dollars a year once we
capture some of that
we will expand to other consumers and go
global
[Music]
our competition are big brands they own
the market and they've been telling
consumers over the years that body wash
comes in a cheap plastic bottle which
ends up in the ocean or on a landfill
smaller startups like ours might compete
with them in some
segments but we rather consider them as
allies as we fight for the same thing
educating consumers to make a switch to
a more sustainable soap
the team that's me and my brother who
currently studies biochemistry
but soon he will have his degree and
since he's a real nature freak he is
full on board to help me develop a
winning formula
my strengths are communication
organization and a clear understanding
of what girls my age want
it took me until sunday night until i
had what i thought was
the perfect pitch
a few days later in the office i saw the
marketing director and took the
initiative
i asked him to give me three minutes of
his time so i could pitch to him but
instead of hearing me out he just said
why don't you pitch it next monday at
the board meeting the old guys are
always open for new ideas from the young
people within the company
maybe they will fund a prototype and do
a market test
then he added with a smile the biggest
secret of getting funding is this
ask for money you'll get advice ask for
advice
and you'll get money i was completely
blown away
i should present my idea to the board
and i knew
exactly what to ask for
[Music]
i couldn't sleep that night i was too
excited about what the marketing
director had told me
the next morning when i went through my
pitch again i wasn't sure if i was
really prepared
i called my former teacher he had
already started several successful
companies
the next day we met and i pitched my
idea to him
after he listened to me my teacher got
really excited and said
if they don't buy your idea on monday
i'll offer to finance you to get started
omg i was so excited
and so thankful
[Music]
on my way home i reflected on my
situation
i wondered if i really want to pitch to
the board and carry on working for the
same company which makes me feel
miserable after all i only worked there
to gain enough experience to start my
own business
i realized that actually i don't want
someone else to buy and sell my idea
i want to try making it myself it was
clear to me that this is my chance to
finally get started
i called my manager thanked him for his
time and told him i'll quit my job to
start my own thing
how about you did you ever try to pitch
your business idea
write down your idea and follow the
different stages like described in this
video and post it in the comments below
or even better why not make a proper
[Music]
presentation